[Music]
so the US Championship in the US Women's
Championship that I've held here in st.
Louis since 2009 you know these events
have become synonymous with st. Louis
and I can't think of a better event to
represent what we do here at the
national pride that comes into it the
talent the diversity of the players that
have come from around the world really
and across the country
all ages from young to old it's great
seeing everybody here welcome players
this is indeed an extremely exciting
time of the year and of course us Hall
of Fame inductee Grand Master Susan
Polgar ladies and gentlemen I now
present to you one of the most
successful female chess players to ever
grace our game Grandmaster Susan Polgar
my proudest moment came in January of
1991 when I became the first woman to
earn the Grandmaster title according to
other regular Fida requirements I
remember after I retired from
competitive just over a decade ago
some people told me it would be easier
for me to get to Mars perhaps than to
get into the Hall of Fame after tonight
perhaps Mars is just a piece of cake
right
[Music]
and now for the fun part for the players
and the way that we determine the order
in which they face each other and with
which color is by drawing numbers you'll
see up here that we have some wonderful
stuffed animals that were purchased here
at the gift shop at the st. Louis Zoo
[Music]
you
you